CSS grin a system for laying out items
across a movable set of horizontal and
vertical lines inside a grid we have
invisible lines that divide columns and
rows the space between two parallel grid
lines is known as a grid track and the
space between four lines is known as a
grid area in your HTML start with a
parent element to serve as your grid
container then all of its children will
automatically become grid items let's
imagine we wanted to build a website
with a holy grail layout in the HTML if
we have a container with five elements
inside we'll start by setting the
containers display property to grid now
open your app in Firefox to visualize
the gridlines tracks and areas it helps
to imagine your website as an Excel
spreadsheet in each individual cell add
a label that represents the element that
should appear there each cell in the
grid represents one fractional unit in
the middle we have an advertisement the
main content and the sidebar then we
have the top bar taking up three cells
on the top and a footer on the bottom
notice how this represents a three by
three grid and we can use this as the
value for the grid template areas
property now we need to tell the
children which grid area that they take
up we can do that by providing the name
to the grid area property that gives us
the right layout but now we want to
adjust the size of the rows and columns
currently each column is taking up one
third or one fractional unit of the
available space we can change the width
of the middle column by setting it to a
fixed pixel value or change the ratio by
giving it three fractional units
likewise we can change the height of
rows using the grid template rows
property if we want to add spacing
between our grid lines we can use the
great gap property and we can Center the
children vertically or horizontally
using justify items or line items and
make sure to check out the min Max and
repeat functions to avoid duplication on
larger grids this has been CSS grid and
100 seconds stay tuned for a full grid
project in a few days and make sure to
hit the like button if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one